we take a look at all of the breaking
news on the Cavanaugh allegations and
there is a lot of it the media humiliate
themselves as per our usual routine
every single day here and we take a look
at the funniest story of the year it is
astonishingly good I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
I stepped away for the final Jewish
holidays guys that was the last ones of
the year okay so now we're safe we're
good now
okay the last couple days first of all I
will say this was the best part of the
Jewish holidays it was Simchat Torah I
know I know you want to get to the news
but I'm just gonna ramble on for a while
about Judaism but in any case it was he
was partying with the Torah was really
great my kids really enjoyed it and now
I am refreshed and I come back and the
news cycle is just rich and replete with
joy and I will bring you all of that
first I want to mention we really
appreciate you tuning in and sharing the
podcast with all of your friends if you
enjoy what we do please subscribe to the
Ben Shapiro show on iTunes and while
you're there leave us a 5-star rating
know but first if you like the show just
do it it takes a second it really helps
us out those ratings on iTunes helped
actually elevate the the ratings on
iTunes overall so make sure that you
leave a five star review for us if you
don't like the show and you want to
leave someone's star rating well then
don't bother doing it you know you got
better things to do today just leave us
five stars because let's face it that's
all we really deserve and now but first
let's talk about your tooth health so
the reality is that you are lying to
your dentist on a routine basis right
you go in there your dentists says how
often you brush you're like eight times
a day every time I breathe I brush my
teeth like well how often you flush like
I haven't stopped flossing you see this
in my mouth right here piece of floss
well you're lying your dentist and we
all know you're lying to your dentist
and that's why you ought to be using
quip instead quip is the best electric
toothbrush on the market it's a fraction
of the cost of bulkier brushes while
still packing just the right amounts of
vibration to help clean your teeth quips
built-in timer helps you clean for the
dentist recommended two minutes with
guiding pulses that remind you when to
switch sides
next equipped subscription plans are for
your health not just convenience they
deliver new brush heads on a dentist
recommended schedule every three months
for just five bucks including free
shipping worldwide finally everyone
loves quip they were on Oprah's olace
they were named one of Times best
inventions and they are the first
subscription electric toothbrush
accepted by the American Dental
Association that is for a reason
it is awesome stuff quip starts just 25
bucks if you go to get quip comm slash
capiro right now you get your first
refill pack free with a quip electric
toothbrush again first refill pack free
at get equipped comm slash Shapiro
that's get quip comm slash app hero so
with the news cycle like this I will say
it is very difficult to take off a
couple of days and then jump right back
into the news cycle I jumped back into
the news cycle yesterday last last night
to find
we are apparently just a couple of days
away from the actual vote on Brett
Kavanaugh that's what Mitch McConnell
said this morning the Senate Majority
Leader says we will be voting on
Kavanagh in the full Senate by the end
of the week the FBI report is expected
to wrap today or tomorrow at the very
latest and the FBI is basically saying
we've got nothing right we've come up
with nakhre they've come up with nothing
new now that doesn't mean the Democrats
are going to accept the FBI report of
course not an allegation about a
Republican is tantamount to the
allegation being true according to folks
on the Left which we'll get to in just a
second according to The Wall Street
Journal though people familiar with the
process said on Tuesday that the FBI
investigation into the allegations of
sexual misconduct against Judge
Cavanaugh could wrap up very soon well
ahead of the end of week deadline which
we hope for and pray for us that we
don't have to spend this weekend
covering breaking news again GOP aides
on the hill and another person familiar
with the process said they were
expecting the bureau to conclude its
report as late as late Tuesday or early
Wednesday agents had interviewed at
least four people as of Tuesday in the
background investigation of Judge
Cavanaugh the White House had given the
bureau until Friday to wrap up the probe
senators will be shown the FBI's
findings it's not clear what exactly
will be made public at any point suffice
it to say it's not expected that
anything groundbreaking will happen here
and there's a reason the Mitch McConnell
is going off on the Democrats over all
of this the Senate Majority Leader he
comes forward he says listen all of this
was a stall tactic all this was a delay
tactic Democrats who had no intention of
voting for Brett Kavanaugh in the first
place are suddenly acting all outraged
that the FBI investigation is wrapping
too soon when they knew it would wrap
that soon because the FBI investigation
actually has less investigative power
than the Senate Judiciary Committee they
can't subpoena documents they can't
subpoena witnesses it's not a criminal
investigation so that means they can go
and ask people to talk to them and they
talk to the people they can talk to but
Democrats are whining anyway here's
Mitch McConnell saying listen we're not
gonna hold this sucker up any longer
we're done here these statements remind
us Democrats may be trying to move the
goalposts every five minutes but their
goal has not moved an inch they will not
be satisfied unless they have brought
down Judge Cavanaugh's nomination and
you can tell Mitch McConnell mean that
is that is cocaine Mitch amped up
there I mean cocaine brilli I'm in that
that's seriously what Mitch McConnell
looks like when he is angry and empty
not a joke
and there's a reason Republicans are
unified on this one and it's because
this feels like a witch-hunt this feels
as though the Democrats are fully intent
on destroying a good man simply for the
sake of delaying a Supreme Court
nomination and the Democrats I will say
there are certain times in American
politics that are very difficult to
watch this is one of those times because
things are so ugly and so acrimonious
and so nasty right now that you find
yourself fulminating about it even when
you don't want to think about politics
the idea that somebody can be railroaded
on one allegation with no corroborate of
evidence and as we will see a lot of
evidence that cuts the other way and
that this is supposed to finish people's
lives if you're a good person you should
be thinking twice about whether this is
the society that you actually want to
live in do you want the possibility that
someone can come forward with an
allegation against you at any time and
destroy you good people will not go into
American public life they won't really
they won't a lot of folks ask me if I
ever want to run for office I will tell
you this ten years ago I was much more
interested in running for office than I
am now and one of the reasons is because
the way people are treated when they run
for office or are on the judiciary or in
in good stead making policy that is not
something you want to put your family
through even if you're as clean as the
driven snow it's not something you want
to put your family through it's also by
the same token well it's difficult to
watch all of this it's also clarifying
and the idea that the bail is being
stripped back and you're seeing people
for who they are one of the people who
we saw who he was over the last several
days and I had to comment on this
because I missed the opportunity to on
Monday was James Comey so Jim's call me
who was touted as the most honest man in
American politics he he lived for a
higher loyalty right he's a higher
loyalty James Comey the FBI director the
president from fired and President Trump
called him a grandstander at the time
and I said President Trump was right to
call him a grandstander and should have
fired immediately upon taking office
well James Comey in the New York Times
had a piece earlier this week and I want
to read you some of the piece because it
sets the baseline for where Democrats
and where folks on the Left were going
with Kavanagh and now it turns out that
none of this is going to come true so
James Comey had a piece earlier this
week and
it was called the FBI can do this and so
the FBI is back in the middle of it when
we were handed the Hillary Clinton email
investigation in 2015 the bureau's
deputy director said to me you know you
are totally screwed right he meant that
in a viciously polarized political
environment one side was sure to be
furious with the outcome sure enough I
saw a tweet declaring me a political
hack
although the author added
tongue-in-cheek I just can't figure out
which side and those were the good old
days president Trump's decision to order
a one-week investigation into sexual
assault allegations against Brett
Kavanaugh his Supreme Court nominee
comes in a time of almost indescribable
pain and anger lies and attacks and he
goes on talks about how terrible the
President of the United States is and
then finally he gets to Brett Kavanaugh
and he suggests that the time-bound
nature of the FBI investigation is
really bad because of course Democrats
felt on the left they don't want
Kavanagh nominated the whole goal of
this investigation the whole goal of
democratic tactics here is to stall
beyond the election that's all they want
now it turns out this is backfiring
radically I will get to the polls in
just a minute
Republicans have not been as unified and
motivated since the 2016 election and
probably since 2010 it's been a long
time since I've seen Republicans this
motivated this unified and that's ready
to go to the polls it's pretty
astonishing but here's the chance Comey
says he says the FBI is now being asked
to investigate on a 7 day clock sexual
assaults that the president says never
happened that some senators have decried
as a sham cooked up to derail a Supreme
Court nominee and that other senators
believe beyond all doubt were committed
by the nominee if truth were the only
goal there would be no clock and the
investigation wouldn't have been sought
after the Senate Judiciary Committee
already endorsed the nominee instead it
seems the Republican goal is to be able
to say there was an investigation and it
didn't change their view while the
Democrats hoped for incriminating
evidence to derail the nominee well no
the Republicans didn't ask for an FBI
investigation because there had already
been six FBI background checks of Brett
Kavanaugh none of them in raised
anything and the Senate Judiciary
Committee as mentioned has more
investigative power than the FBI they
went ahead with this because Jeff Flake
felt that maybe this would make some of
the senators sitting on the fence a
little bit more comfortable but James
Comey continues he says although the
process is deeply flawed and apparently
designed to thwart the fact gathering
process the FBI is up for this it's not
as hard as Republicans hope it will be
FBI agents are experts at interviewing
people and quickly to
leads to their colleagues around the
world to follow with additional
interviews
unless limited in some way by the Trump
administration they can speak to scores
of people in a few days if necessary
they will confront people with testimony
and other accounts testing them pushing
them in a professional way
agents have much better nonsense
detectors than partisans because they
aren't starting with a conclusion this
is the best part yes
the alleged incident occurred 36 years
ago but FBI agents know time has very
little to do with memory and this is
what is the former FBI director saying
the time has very little to do with
memory that is an insane statement that
is insane scientific evidence proves
that memory has nearly everything to do
with time that the further something is
in the past the worse you remember it
you may think you remember something
clearly the truth is you probably don't
I love this from James Comey says FBI
agents know every married person
remembers the weather on their wedding
day no matter how long ago significance
drives memory they also know that little
lies point to bigger lies they know that
obvious lies by the nominee about the
meaning of words in a yearbook are a
flashing signal to dig deeper so James
Comey already condemning Kavanagh as a
liar even though Cavanaugh actually
hadn't lied about anything and there's
no proof Kavanagh lied about anything
we'll get to that in just a second but I
love this comment he says that FBI
agents know that time has little to do
with memory and that significance drives
memory because everybody remembers what
the weather was like on their wedding
day first of all the reason you remember
anything on your wedding day is because
there was a photographer there taking
pictures of the whole thing and then you
go back and you look at the pictures of
your wedding day and that is what you
call an aid to memory second of all if
his argument is that everyone knows what
the weather was like on their wedding
day then why doesn't Christine blazed
before remember where it happened when
it happened what the weather was like on
that day who drove her there who drove
her home who else was at the party she
doesn't remember anything
so significance drives memory then why
exactly doesn't she remember anything
about what happened except supposedly
the Brett Kavanaugh was there so all of
this is completely self-defeating it's
just
but James Comey you know acting as the
supposed good guy in the room the
objective observer in the room is
already inciting Brett Kavanaugh without
even recognizing that his own words
basically undercut the testimony of
Christine Blasi Ford this is where we
are people who are purport
to be objective are just falsifying
people who are purporting to be
objective on this instead of saying we
don't have enough information yet
already did beginning of the week they
were saying the Kavanagh is guilty and
that was the expectation the Kavanagh
was going to be guilty and that no
matter what happened we could be assured
that something would arise they would
stop Brett Cavanaugh's nomination
instead as it turns out there's some
evidence that is now arising suggesting
that Christine Blasi Ford has lied and
lied repeatedly now these are
uncorroborated allegations of lies from
Christine blaze before but no more
uncorroborated than Ford's testimony
itself so the same people who are saying
that the testimony that's now been given
put forth about Christine Blasi Ford the
same people saying that that's
uncorroborated stuff are perfectly fine
with her uncorroborated testimony
destroying Brett Kavanaugh so either you
want evidence corroborated or you don't
want evidence corroborated you don't get
to pick and choose you don't get to say
the Bret cabinet should be taken down on
the basis of uncorroborated allegations
but Christine Blasi Ford testimony
should be respected until it is
disproved by corroborated allegations
either corroborate of evidence is
necessary or corroborate of evidence is
not necessary we'll get to the holes in
christine blazing ford's story in just
one second but first let's talk about
how you can save money so these days as
you may have noticed it's pretty tough
to get people to agree on anything but
there's one thing we can all get behind
and that is saving the DOE
honey is a free shopping tool that
automatically searches the internet for
the best promo codes every single time
you buy something online
honey believes everyone deserves the
best prices possible on all of the
things they like which is why honey
works on all your favorite sites Amazon
eBay j.crew Walmart Best Buy Groupon all
of them in fact honey has already saved
listeners of this podcast an average of
$26 and 34 cents that's how many
listeners of this podcast have used
honey and how much money they're saving
you know over on Amazon I shop on Amazon
all the time the other day I bought a
series of books from Amazon and because
of and because of honey I was able to
get a discount on the books Amazon is
just that good and so is honey right if
it weren't for honey I would be getting
a more expensive deal I buy stuff from
Amazon all the time honey helps me early
every time I shop honey has 10 million
members over a hundred thousand five
star reviews honey is the money saving
shopping tool everybody can agree on get
honey for free at join honey calm slash
Ben that's join honey calm slash Ben
honey is the easiest way to save money
while shopping online again go to
join honey calm / Ben to check it out
okay so here is the bad news for
Christine Blasi Ford there's a letter
that is now out from Christine blaze
ephors ex-boyfriend and this letter is
not good for Christine lazy Ford is a
state it is a statement given under
penalty of perjury so if the person's
lying then they could be brought up on
charges and here's what it says this was
turned over to Fox News I blank I'm a
current resident of California I first
met Christine Blasi now dr. Christine
Blasi Ford in 1989 or 1990 in California
from 1990 to 1991 I was just friends
with Ford from approximately 1992 to
1998 I was in a relationship with dr.
Ford
I found her truthful and maintained no
animus towards her during our time
dating dr. Ford never brought up
anything regarding her experience as a
victim of sexual assault harassment or
mr. conduct dr. Ford never mentioned
Brett Kavanaugh during some of the time
we were dating dr. Ford lived with
Monica Elle McLean who I understood to
be her lifelong best friend during that
time it was my understanding that McLean
was interviewing for jobs with the FBI
and US Attorney's office I witness dr.
Ford helped McLean prepare for a
potential polygraph exam dr. Ford
explained in detail what to expect how
polygraphs worked and helped McLean
become familiar and less nervous about
the exam dr. Ford was able to help
because of her background in psychology
dr. Ford and I lived together while we
were dating and stayed together in a
long-distance relationship when dr. Ford
moved to Hawaii sometime around 1998
although I'm not sure of the particular
year and it might have been a bit
earlier or later
well visiting Ford in Hawaii we traveled
around the Hawaiian Islands including
one time on a propeller plane dr. Ford
never indicated a fear of flying to the
best of my recollection dr. Ford never
expressed a fear of closed quarters
tight spaces or places with only one
exit I assisted dr. Ford with finding a
place to live in California she ended up
living in a very small 500 square foot
house with one door despite trying to
maintain a long-distance relationship I
ended the relationship once I discovered
dr. Ford was unfaithful while living in
Hawaii after the breakup I took her off
the credit card we shared but nearly one
year later I noticed dr. Ford had been
charging the card and charged about $600
worth of merchandise when confronted dr.
Ford said she did not use the card but
later admitted to the use after I
threatened to involve fraud prevention I
didn't speak to Ford again until about
2002 when Ford contact me me briefly
after that I hadn't thought much about
her until I saw her story in The
Washington Post on Sunday September 16
2018 I do not want to become involved in
this process
Curren investigation but wanted to be
truthful about what I know so pretty
damning stuff from her ex-boyfriend
about kristinb lacy Ford really
undercutting her veracity in just a
second I'll explain why so this letter
suggests a couple of reasons why dr.
Ford's veracity has been challenged one
she never mentioned for years
anything about this sexual assault never
mentioned Kavanagh now that doesn't
necessarily undercut all of her
credibility
according to Ford she never said
anything until 2012 but it does
underscore that for a lady who says that
she was very disturbed about everything
that happened to her with regard to
Kavanagh not to mention it for six seven
years and also to be able to travel in
prop planes like I'm nervous about
traveling in prop planes like propeller
planes feel like they're gonna go down
at any moment and she feels she was
traveling in prop planes in Hawaii she
was staying apparently according to this
guy in tiny spaces with no worries about
claustrophobia she testified in front of
the Senate all of this also she
testified in front of the Senate she'd
never coached anybody with regard to a
polygraph remember she made a big deal
out of taking the polygraph and she
still won't turn over her notes from her
psychiatrist she turned over her
polygraph notes but her polygraph notes
raised some questions of their own such
as in the polygraph notes the original
polygraph note said before she took the
polygraph that she was sexually
assaulted in the early 80s she crossed
out early nobody knows why because
supposedly the assault happened in 1982
then she took the polygraph and then she
passed the polygraph but she testified
under oath that she did not coach anyone
on a polygraph now her ex-boyfriend says
that's not true here is her testifying
about this under oath I didn't expect it
to be as long as it was going to be so
is a little bit stressful have you ever
given tips or advice to somebody who was
looking to take a polygraph test
never okay and it turns out that that is
a serious question for her were you
lying about that so janitor chuck
Grassley has now sent a letter to the
attorneys for this woman for Christine
Blasi form and he asked for material
evidence relevant to the allegations he
says he wants some corroborate of
evidence he says he wants the notes from
therapy sessions that dr. Ford discussed
and that she turned over to the
Washington Post right he says that he
wants copies of all video or audio
recordings produced during the course of
the polygraph examination of dr. Ford
which she will not turn over and then he
says the full details of
affords polygraph are particularly
important because the Senate Judiciary
Committee has received a sworn statement
from a longtime boyfriend of dr. Ford's
stating that he personally witnessed dr.
Ford coaching a friend on polygraph
examinations when asked under oath in
the hearing whether she'd ever given any
tips or advice to someone who's planning
on taking a polygraph
dr. forum replied never this statement
raises specific concerns about the
reliability of her polygraph examination
results the Senate therefore needs this
information so she's got a credibility
problem there as well
then she also has another credibility
problem it turns out that she said in
her Senate testimony over and over again
that she was in therapy in 2012 because
she had a fight with her husband about
building a second front door and the
reason that she wanted a second front
door is because she had security
concerns because she was still deeply
disturbed about her alleged sexual
assault at the hands of Brett Kavanaugh
well now it turns out that that's a
really dicey story real clear
investigations Paul Sperry over real
clear investigations has a piece in
which he says real estate and other
records undercut a key part of Christine
Blasi Ford's accounts of why she finally
came forward with charges of attempted
rape against Supreme Court nominee Brett
Kavanaugh after some 30 years for
testified last week that she had never
revealed the details of the alleged
attack until 2012 when she was in
couples therapy with her husband she
said the memories percolated up as they
revisited a disagreement they'd had over
her insistence on installing a second
front door when they remodeled their
Palo Alto California home the need to
explain a decision her husband didn't
understand pushed her to say she wanted
at the door to alleviate symptoms of
claustrophobia and panic attacks based
on the alleged assault
she was specifically asked about this by
Dianne Feinstein Feinstein asked is that
the reason for the second front door is
claustrophobia and Ford said correct but
documents reveal the door was installed
years before as part of an addition and
has been used by renters and even a
marriage counseling business the door
was not an escape route but an entrance
routes had an attorney familiar with the
ongoing congressional investigation it
appears the real plan for the second
front door was to rent out a separate
room pal
LTC palo alto city records show a
building permit for the additional room
and exterior door was issued to ford and
her husband On February 4 2008 more than
four years before the May 2012 therapy
session where she first identified
Cavanaugh as her attacker all the
remodeling was completed by February
2010 the
additional permits issued to Ford at her
Palo Alto address are for solar panels
on the roof a solar hot water system in
the garage an electric vehicle charge
station for the driveway
dr. Randall who is the marriage
therapist expressed concerns about her
real estate transaction and prior
relationship with Ford being reported
she said I don't want it mentioned it's
personal since the second front door is
installed students from local colleges
have lived in the additional room with
the private door so in other words there
are a lot of holes in her story we don't
know where we don't know when we don't
know that she's actually claustrophobic
we don't know we certainly know that
she's okay with flying for the most part
Lea she does it a fair bit we also know
that that second front door story has
some holes in it all of which suggests
that maybe there are some serious
questions that need to be asked about
Ford's account and this week it seems
more questions have been raised about
that account than have actually been
raised about Brett Kavanaugh now just a
second I'm against the president Trump's
response on all of this which is you
know peculiarly trumpian but first let's
talk about you saving money on stamps so
these days you could go to the post
office post office a great place a lot
of great services but you're gonna spend
time in the car you're gonna spend time
in line or you could sit at your desk
and get all the fantastic services of
the post office you know right there at
your desk and that's where stamps calm
comes in with Sam's calm you can access
all the amazing services of the post
office right from your desk 24/7 when it
is convenient for you buy and print
official US postage for any letter any
package using your own computer and
printer the mail carrier picks it up
just click print mail you're done we use
it here at daily wire offices all the
time it saves us a bundle on not only
the postage but also it saves us an
enormous amount of money on having to
travel back and forth to the post office
and then spend the money on the gas and
lose the time during the day for the
folks who work here right now use promo
code Shapiro for a special offer from
stamps comm it includes up to fifty five
bucks of free postage a digital scale
and a four week trial don't wait go to
stamps calm before you do anything else
click on the radio microphone at the top
of the homepage type in Shapiro that
stamps comm enter promo code Shapiro go
check it out right now stamps comm promo
code Shapiro
okay so president Trump has basically
had it after a couple of weeks of him
maintaining silence or at least being
discreet in his opinions about this
issue him saying that he found her
testimony compelling and then he found
Cavanaugh's testimony compelling the
president last night decided you know
done screw this no more of this so he
did a rally and at the rally he decided
to launch into Christine lazy for it now
there are some folks on the right saying
that the president was not mocking
Christine Blasi for he's pretty clearly
mocking Christine Blasi Ford there are
some folks on the Left saying he was
only mocking Christine blizzy Ford no he
was also mocking the fact that her
corroboration free allegation is being
taken entirely seriously despite its
lack of detail so two things can be true
at once number one he can be saying
basically true things about the serious
holes in christine blazing Ford's story
- he probably shouldn't be mocking
Christine Blasi Ford it's bad politics
and it's cruel and there's no reason to
do it but here is the president going
after Christine Boise Ford in his
typically entertaining fashion how did
you get home I don't remember how'd you
get there I don't remember where is the
place I don't remember how many years
ago was it I don't know I don't know I
don't know what neighborhood was it in I
don't know where's the house at her room
upstairs Downstairs where was I don't
know but I had one beer that's the only
thing I remember okay so there's the
president going off on her this of
course allows the Democrats the reason
it's bad strategy is it allows the
Democrats to misdirect from Kavanagh to
Trump now they can act all outraged even
though there's serious questions about
Christine Blasi Ford's story and again
no corroboration in fact counter
corroboration every witness she has
cited has said they don't remember this
party every single witness she has cited
said they do not remember this party
there is no corroborating evidence none
okay but this will let because Trump is
mouthing off this allows the Democrats
to jump on this which is what they do
CNN's Don Lemon says he can't resist
mocking her it's just so terrible how
could he possibly mock her well I would
point out like I don't like the mop her
either but I would point out the entire
media have been mocking Brett Kavanaugh
SNL did an entire thing about how Brett
Kavanaugh got emotional and they had
Matt Damon you remember Matt Damon the
guy who's ripped apart by the me2
movement like five minutes ago
now he's they're playing the me two
movements go-to guy
mocking Brett cabinet so find him out
Brett Kavanaugh a guy whose life is
being torn apart by what appeared to be
corroboration free allegations of rape
and stand false allegations of gang rape
that guy you can knock the crap out of
but if you might Christine Blasi Ford
according to see
that's the true test of evil now again I
don't think any of these folks should be
mocked but here is Don Lemon going after
President Trump which is why you know
the president should think twice before
doing this sort of stuff in the future
so we learned tonight that our president
cannot resist mocking a woman who he had
called a credible witness in front of a
cheering crowd and we're learning more
tonight about Brett Kavanaugh as well a
letter there's a letter it was obtained
by the New York Times it was written in
1983 we have a copy here when he was 18
years old
Cavanaugh writing to his high school
buddies he says this and I'm quoting
we're loud obnoxious drunks with
prolific pukers among us oh my god he
drank in high school no I've never heard
of such a thing except from every high
school student who's ever been in high
school okay really this is we'll get to
the shifting goalposts of the Democrats
and the media in just a second because
the goalposts are moving faster than the
speed of light I didn't think it was
possible it shouldn't be by the laws of
physics it's not possible to move faster
than the speed of light but somehow
those goal posts have been shifting
faster than the speed of light we've
actually gone back in time thanks to the
goalposts shifting of the Democrats it's
truly incredible we got to all that in
in just second but mazie Hirono also
attacking president Trump how dare
President Trump remember mazie Hirono is
one of the people who said all men
should sit down and shut up and say
nothing about the Brett Kavanaugh
allegations okay so she's a real great
source when it comes to I think honesty
in politics but here she is just
lamenting the state of our politics
after having helped to undermine it
after having clocked politics in the
back of the head with a shovel and left
it bleeding through the nose here she is
talking to Anderson Cooper we can always
count on the President to go down to the
lowest common denominator mock people
call people names attack them this is
what he does and the thing that dr. Ford
did remember with 100% recollection was
that it was Brett Kavanaugh who attacked
her okay so there we have it and because
she said it therefore it must be true
see and believe that's not that's all
we've got it turns out that other
allegations with regard to the the
nominee are also following apart there
was an NBC story about Brett Kavanaugh
this one had to do with Deborah Ramirez
and it accused
of perjury and then it turns out that he
was not in fact guilty of perjury so
here's what NBC originally reported they
said the text between Bertram and Karen
yarra Savage both Friends of Cavanaugh
suggest the nominee was personally
talking with former classmates about
Deborah Ramirez's story in advance of
the New Yorker article that made her
allegation public remember Deborah
Ramirez is the lady who alleged that at
some frat party at Yale
Brent Cavanaugh exposed himself in front
of her in one message yarrow savage said
Cavanaugh asked her to go on record in
his defense two other messages show
communication between Cavanaugh steam
and former classmates in advance of the
story the texts also demonstrate that
Cavanaugh and Ramirez were more socially
connected than previously understood and
that Ramirez was uncomfortable around
Cavanaugh and they saw each other at a
wedding 10 years after they graduated
bertram zephyr - also show that some
potential witnesses have been unable to
get important information to the FBI on
Monday a senior US official confirmed
the White House has authorized the FBI
to expand its initially limited
investigation okay that was the original
report then they went back and stealth
edited and here's what they added in now
public transcripts from an interview
with the Republican Judiciary Committee
staff on September 25th two days after
the mere the Ramirez allegations were
reported in The New Yorker Cavanaugh
claimed it was Ramirez who was calling
around to classmates trying to see if
they remembered it adding it strikes me
as you know what is going on here when
someone is calling around to try and
refresh other people is that what's
going on what's going on with that that
doesn't sound good it doesn't sound good
to me it doesn't sound fair it doesn't
sound proper it sounds like an
orchestrated hit to take me out so in
other words NBC first claim that
Cavanaugh is calling around to try and
quash Ramirez his story and now it turns
out that he had already testified he'd
already testified that as Ramirez who
was calling around to try and bolster
her story so good job media well done
all the way through there's another
allegation that seems to be having some
trouble then there's the allegation from
Julie sweat Nick this of course coming
from Michael avenatti it turns out that
a former boyfriend of Julie sweat Nick
has now issued a letter to the to the
Senate Judiciary Committee and here is
what it says my name is Dennis Keller
I'm a former weeknight media
meteorologist for channel 7 in
Washington DC and won an Emmy in 1995 I
want to preface this by saying I'm
neither proud nor guiltless in the
actions about to be mentioned in this
letter I hope my friends family and
church members can forgive me I first
met Julie sweat Nick in 1993 at a
Washington DC bar near Wisconsin circle
I was
going-away party for Channel seven and
Cordell Sally I left the party to go to
the bar to buy a soda I haven't drunk
alcohol since my 18th birthday as I sat
alone at the end of the bar Julie
approached me she was alone quite
beautiful well-dressed and no drink in
hand consequently my initial thought was
that she might be a high-end call girl
because at the time I weighed 350 pounds
so it would someone like her want with
me but there was no conversation about
exchanging sex for money so I decided to
talk with her a few minutes I had never
been hit down in a bar before I didn't
leave with her that night although we
talked about getting together over the
next couple of weeks we met at what I
believed and still believe with Julie's
place from the beginning Julie knew I
was married and that I was having
marital issues he says she was an
opportunist I felt she had only interest
in my 350-pound self because I was on TV
and well-known although we were not
emotionally involved there was physical
contact we never had sex despite the
fact she was very sexually aggressive
with me and then he talks about all of
her fantasies
you know sets with multiple guys and he
suggests that she is politically
motivated and he says that basically
she's not to be believed he basically
calls her a sociopath and so that's
that's not great for her accounts either
and her her account always was was
really troublesome right the gang rape
account was always very difficult to
substantiate considering there should
have been witnesses for any of that
stuff we're gonna get to a final
allegation that Democrats tried to bring
up last minute in just one second but
first let's talk about your nutrition
okay right now take a look at your
superfood container okay it has a
Supplemental facts panel that means it
is made from extract instead of real
food well the folks over at brickHouse
nutrition have decided that they needed
to create a real superfood that is
specially designed to enhance your
health and help you reach your full
potential and it's called field of
greens fields of grains is the first
real superfood the difference that sets
it apart can be seen on the bottle it
has a nutrition facts panel because it
is indeed real food one scoop a field of
greens has a full serving of real
certified vegan vegetarian and USDA
organic fruits and vegetables complete
with antioxidants it's a daily clean
green energy that fuels your body for a
healthier happier lifestyle field of
greens has also become the energy choice
of the USA men's Olympic wrestling team
because it does indeed really work we
have folks around the office who have
tried it they say that it's really good
if you act now get a limited time offer
by texting Shapiro to four one four one
one again text Shapiro to four one four
one you can't ask for better then it's
the energy choice that US men's Olympic
wrestling team here are you on the
Olympic men's wrestling team I didn't
think so go check it out right now
Brickhouse been calm experience a better
you tomorrow go check it out Brickhouse
been calm and text Shapiro two four one
four one one again Shapiro two four one
four one one get energy a much more
natural way field of greens has it for
you go check it out right now
Brickhouse been calm or Shapiro texts it
two four one four one one okay so we're
gonna get two more of these allegations
and the best story of the day it really
is a spectacular story we'll get to all
of that in just a second first you're
gonna have to go over to Daily wire this
Friday daily wire is launching the next
chapter in Andrew Clayton's podcast
series another Kingdom performed by
Michael Knowles if you aren't caught up
on the first season it's available on
the website subscribers today Lee Weyer
get early access to each episode and all
of it is ad free this season we've added
a dramatic visual component so really is
pretty cool if you've never listened to
it it really is great stuff despite the
fact that Michael Knowles does the
reading you know he does a good job with
it actually he doesn't just sit there
and stare blankly into camera as usual
so it is worth subscribing just for it
it's really fun and really interesting
go check it out right now at daily
wired.com and subscribe to 9 a month get
the rest of this show live as well plus
you get to send us questions in the
mailbag which we'll be doing this week
also when you subscribe at YouTube or
iTunes where you should leave us a
review at iTunes as I mentioned earlier
you'll also get access to our Sunday
special this week Sunday special is a
guy band winingham on for a very long
time
Jonathan Hite professor at NYU the
author of the righteous mind and the new
New York Times bestseller the coddling
of the American mind he stopped by to
talk about free speech college campus
and all the rest hi my name is jonathan
height and i'm gonna be talking with Ben
on the Ben Shapiro show Sunday special
I'll be talking about my new book the
coddling of the American mind as well as
the inexplicable puzzling events that
have consumed much of campus life and
national politics so you only want to
check that out by the way if you want a
preview of what exactly that's gonna be
like Thursday night I'm speaking at USC
there's already talk that things are
going to get maybe riotous outside and
kind of insane over there so always
looking forward to that I can't just
have like a normal speech to a bunch of
people that always have some chaos so
we're gonna do that on Thursday night
that will be lots of fun also I want to
thank you if you were folks before you
sign off here I just want to thank you
if you if you watched our Sunday special
our Fox News special on Sunday
really
to thank our ratings were bananas again
really great ratings this Sunday
actually increased over our first Sunday
show and the show this Sunday this
coming Sunday is gonna be awesome as
well so I encourage you to tune in over
there
we're the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
okay so the final allegation those
brought by Democrats again all the
allegations are falling apart
the final allegation that was brought
against Brett Kavanaugh was brought last
minute by Senator Chris Coons so here is
the accusation apparently Chris Coons
forwarded an allegation related to Judge
Cavanaugh's years in New Haven
the accuser who apparently created a TV
show in which people strip while dancing
to their favorite music which is an
awesome TV show probably tells of a
party that took place at the house of
judge Cavanaugh under grant fraternity
during the 1987 to 1988 school year and
which allegedly featured some salacious
activity of course judge Cavanaugh had
already graduated when this party
allegedly took place and was a
first-year law student that period is as
well know most academically intense time
in most students lives
this allegations has all the makings of
a tabloid headline but there's just one
problem
the accuser freely admits to having no
evidence whatsoever that Judge Cavanaugh
even attended this party this chuck
grassley slapping the crap out of Chris
Coons rather than provide even
circumstantial evidence of Judge
Cavanaugh's attendance the accuser
provides some investigative evidence he
proposes that someone searched judge
Cavanaugh's calendars the very same
calendars your colleagues have dismissed
and derided to determine whether he
attended a frat party at some point in
1987 or 1988 and that's it all he
alleges that he once witnessed a
salacious party at a house owned by
Judge Cavanaugh's undergrad fraternity
and then separately advises us to obtain
and search judge Cavanaugh's calendars
to determine if he attended we have
reached a new level of absurdity with
this allegation there is no evidence the
judge Cavanaugh is anywhere near the
party or had anything to do with it at
all in fact the only person we can be
sure attended the party was the accuser
my investigators have serious work to do
while the minority has refused to engage
with the allegations against judge
Cavanaugh in any meaningful way my
investigators have tried to pursue every
relevant lead I therefore hope that
before forwarding an allegation in the
future you'll first consider whether
you'd want you or your staff to spend
valuable time investigating it thanks
for your consideration honestly I got a
love chuck grassley at this point dude
just does not give any apps at this
point he's like you know what we're done
we are just done here we are finished
it's just great because he said the same
thing to Bernie Sanders earlier this
week Bernie Sanders sent him a letter
saying we want a longer FBI
investigation and Grassley sends him a
letter back saying Bernie you came out
five minutes after the nomination and
said that you were going to oppose
Cavanaugh
you think I can change your mind if you
change your mind maybe we'll talk about
it it's just it's amazing so all of this
leads up to the fact that there's just a
shifting argument going on in the left
this started off if you recall with an
argument that Brett Calvin was unfit for
the court because he allegedly tried to
rape a girl when he was 17 right that
was the original allegation then it
turned into gang rape that's turned out
to be false then it turned into exposing
himself at a party no evidence of that
then it turned into okay well maybe it's
cuz he got angry right so he's angry we
can't have angry people on the court
because Ruth Bader Ginsburg seems like a
delight I Ruth Bader Ginsburg who goes
out and rants as RBG the notorious RBG
yeah and she goes out and she rants
politically every five minutes she's
perfectly she's perfectly well balanced
to me on the court but Brett Cavan who
got mad when you accused him of being a
gang rapists doesn't belong on the court
the shift in goal parts posts are just
insane here's Hillary Clinton saying
Brett Cavanaugh's behavior is out of
bounds well I mean Hillary you want to
be President and you drank John McCain
under a table and threw a lamp at her
husband so there's that hey here's
Hillary Clinton wearing again something
that she got from Mugabe 'he's wardrobe
in in Zoolander but I think for anyone
who believes there's such a thing as a
judicial temperament and that we want
judges particularly those on our highest
court to approach issues approach
plaintiffs and defendants with a sense
of fairness that there's a lot to be
concerned about yeah because he got mad
when you accused him of being I remember
someone else getting mad when when her
husband was accused of rape
I remember that who would that have been
accused of sexual assault that was
probably true I remember somebody
getting mad about that oh yeah and she
want to be President in the United
States by the way I should correct my
zeal and a reference it's Mugatu not
Mugabe Mugabe was a dictator of Zimbabwe
well God - it's the Bugatti was a
character from Zoolander okay how else
did this shift the standards so Alison
Cammarata on CNN there's a story about
how Brett Kavanaugh back when he was in
college got in a bar fight with a guy
who threw some ice at a guy all right
now let me explain how this works I went
to Harvard Law School a lot of great
minds there a lot of these folks will be
senators the people who are in my class
and there's a group of guys who would go
out they invited me but I this as you
will hear this is not my type of party
it would go out to bars
they'll get drunk off their butts and
then they would just sock each other in
the nuts okay not not a joke like they
would actually just punch each other in
the groin like this is an actual thing
that I would hear about later as you can
imagine not my kind of party okay but
the accusation here by Alison cammarata
is that ice throwers are more likely to
assault so if you're in a bar fight with
a dude at a bar and you threw ice at him
then it must be that you sexually
assaulted a woman years prior makes
perfect sense makes perfect sense
I'm with you all the way Alison by the
way all the members of Congress who are
very upset about drinking if they say
that you know heavy drinking is more
likely to make you a sexual assault sir
I have some bad news for the folks in
Congress
hey the folks in Congress that place is
an unmet a a meeting hey if anybody ever
wanted to win a Pulitzer all they would
have to do is just stake out the bars on
Capitol Hill the number of Congress
people who are fall down drunks is
astonishing in any case here's the
Alison cammarata making a fool of
herself I think that if you are known as
a belligerent mean fighting drunk that's
relevant I think that it's relevant to
then a woman who says that you would
corner her and put your hand over her
mouth somehow that I think makes more
sense than if you were just a fun drunk
who always fell right asleep okay or
alternatively the two things don't
necessarily have to do with one another
because guys get in bar fights with
other dudes and then they may not touch
women because that happens actually a
fair bit cuz that's reality that's
that's called men with testosterone
being drunken Jake jackasses like whoa I
swear it's like these people have never
met a man it's it's an incredible
incredible thing okay and then the
goalposts shifted even more so we'll get
to that in just one second so the
goalposts continue to chef Bernie
Sanders who has no intention of voting
for Brett Kavanaugh he says you know
what we need more time that's what we
need more time because I am very old and
I cannot comprehend things at the speed
at which I once used to comprehend all
of the pudding and therefore we need
more time sure I'm not going to vote for
him but that does not matter it does not
matter at all at all at all
Bernie talk go what has to happen now is
the FBI needs to do a full investigation
determining his veracity it's not a
question of drinking everybody you know
millions of people in America drink it's
a question of whether you are lying
before the Judiciary Committee of the
United States Senate if you are lying
you should not be seated and by the way
that investigation should be thorough
should not be limited to a week and the
idea that we are voting or being asked
about before this report can be read is
totally crazy okay so that's the news
story they're not taking enough time
that's that's the real problem here if
they just took more time and then you
have Jeffrey Toobin who basically sums
it up at the very end Jeffrey Toobin
essentially says you know what you know
what I don't care whether he's guilty or
innocent he's white which is rich coming
from Jeffrey Toobin a white dude who
knocked up his mistress tried to pay for
her abortion refused to pay child
support until ordered to buy a quart but
he says that every allegation should be
taken seriously well he sits there on
CNN with his job after trying to pay for
an abortion and ditch his child support
necessities good job Jeffrey Toobin
here he is saying he cries himself to
sleep over the fate of white men America
the innate sexism of the statement the
white men America don't actually deserve
due process now I'm not a big fan of the
victimology white men are victims white
men or black people are victims or gays
or victims or Jews are victim I'm not a
big fan America is a free country
nobody's a victim unless you can show me
proof of victimhood this right here is
proof of victimhood when the CNN lead
legal analyst says that white men do not
deserve due process or the presumption
of innocence that actually is pretty
good evidence of actual racism and
sexism taking place here's Jeffrey
Toobin doing it I cry myself to sleep
over the fate of white men in America
white men have no power
white men I mean it's such garbage I
mean all this whining about the poor
plight of white men is ridiculous can I
say one OK it's not we're not crying
about the plight of white men there's a
white man who is being railroaded based
on no presumption of innocence and you
guys are cheering it on how are we
supposed to react I would hope that
people of every color would be a little
upset when a certain group is singled
out and then told that mob rule should
prevail mob rule has been historically
very bad for minorities in this country
that's the reason due process is such an
important thing it's why
part of the Fourteenth Amendment and not
just part of the Fifth Amendment because
the idea was due process had to be
extended to all Americans it's it's
pretty astonishing now all of this is in
fact unifying Republicans it should I
mean you have Cory Booker that insane
bag of lunacy who says the senator from
New Jersey
spartacus he came out and he says that
it actually he finally spills the beans
just as listen it doesn't matter whether
Cavanaugh is guilty or innocent I don't
like him because I'm bald or something
here is the era's Cory Booker and his
crazy eyes and then ultimately not
whether he's innocent or guilty this is
not a trial but ultimately have enough
questions be raised that we should not
move on to another candidate and that
long list put together by the Heritage
Foundation believable it doesn't matter
if he's guilty or innocent but have
enough questions been raised ok mr.
Potatohead
got up this morning when it put on his
angry eyes Cory freaking Booker yeah and
then they wonder why Republicans are so
united so here's the here's the
hilarious thing Democrats thought this
was gonna unite them oopsy-daisy it
turns out that the Quinnipiac ballot
shows that the Jeanette the the
Democratic generic ballot lead has been
sliced in half in a month has been
sliced in half as I said last week you
know we did a little kind of Q&A I was
doing a live radio show and in the
middle of the breaks I was answering
questions which we do for subscribers
which is why you should subscribe and
somebody asked you know do you think
Republicans will be more motive and I
said I know I am if I if it weren't
illegal I would go register to vote
eight times in Ohio because yes yes
forty-nine percent of Americans back the
Democratic candidate in their local race
for the US House 42 percent support the
Democratic candidate that is a massive
decrease in the Democratic support level
okay when Democrats had a 14-point lead
it's now down to seven in the Quinnipiac
polls it is possible that Republicans
retain the house because Democrats are
so disgusting which would just be poetic
justice
wouldn't that be phenomenal if the
Republicans retain the house because of
Brett Kavanaugh that would just first of
all the insanity that is likely to break
out on the back of that will just be
unbelievable and things will just be
nuts Oh nuts oppa's Uncas as I say to my
children it'll be crazy so we can all
look forward to
that okay now I have to get to my
favorite story of the day so this is
indeed the best story of the day it is a
fantastic story it's so good so it turns
out there are these three professors and
these three professors Helen pluck Rose
James Lindsay and Peter pegasion and
they decided to prank all of these
stupid academic journals out there the
story is so great I love it so much here
is Peter pegasi and explaining what
exactly they did to prank these journals
since approximately June of 2017 I along
with two other concerned academics Peter
Berg ocean and Helen cluck Rose have
been writing intentionally broken
academic papers and submitting them to
highly respected journals and fields
that study gender race sexuality and
similar topics we did this to expose a
political corruption has taken hold of
the university by this point several of
these papers have been accepted in
highly respected journals and one that
claims that dog humping incidents can be
taken as evidence of rape culture has
been officially honored as excellent
scholarship I'm not going to lie to you
we had a lot of fun with this project
but don't let that lead you to believe
that we're not addressing a serious
problem if you have a few minutes I'll
try to explain okay it's so good it's so
good so what did they do they submitted
all of these insane papers to these
feminists and Gender Studies journals
and they all got printed and the papers
are unreal so there's the dog park paper
you heard him described there about why
dog humping incidents our rape culture I
talked about on the show here there's
another one so at the crota paper excuse
me it's so good
they wrote a paper claiming that when a
guy privately pleasures himself while
thinking about a woman without her
consent
in fact without her ever finding out
about it that he's committed sexual
violence against her that was printed in
a queer studies journal okay they argue
they today wrote a paper arguing that
the reason super intelligent AI is
potentially dangerous is because it is
being programmed
I want to give these people a medal they
argue that the reason super intelligent
AI is potentially dangerous is because
it is being programmed to be masculinist
an imperialist using Mary Shelley's
Frankenstein and Lacanian psychoanalysis
that's their feminist AI paper they
argued that a fat body is a legitimately
built body as a foundation for
introducing a category for fat body
building into the sport of professional
bodybuilding a journal called fat
studies it's so good they they found
something called feminist Glaciology
okay this is a real thing apparently so
they copied the idea and then they wrote
a feminist astronomy paper arguing the
feminist and queer astrology should be
considered part of the science of
astronomy which will brand as
intrinsically sexist and researchers
loved it then they wrote a paper about
trans people in the workplace says men
use male preserves to enact dying macho
masculinity is just masculinities
discourses in a way society at large
won't accept they published a paper best
summarised as quote a gender scholar
goes to Hooters to try to figure out why
it exists okay it's so it's so great D
familiarising common experience is
pretending to be mystified by them and
then looking for social constructions to
explain him sure oh man I can't even
read this one on the air Wow
it's it would be so I'll try to explain
this in the most PG rated possible way
wow this is gonna be a challenge so they
did a paper on certain toys implements
that are used in times of intimacy
typically by men who are not straight so
that they ask the question why don't
straight men tend to pleasure themselves
via use of these implements that are
general
used by gay men and what would happen if
they did and their paper was printed in
sexuality and culture when they
concluded that men would be less
transphobic and more feminist if they
allowed themselves to be treated in a
way that straight men typically are not
particularly fond of you know that they
tried to avoid why we tried to avoid
going to the proctologist as often as
possible I had the very best one of
course the very best one is that they
they submitted a paper to the social the
feminist Social Work Journal of philia
okay this is what they did a feminist
rewrite of a chapter from mine Kampf
they literally took a chapter from mine
Kampf their play some of the language
with feminist language and they
submitted it to affiliate affiliate
Princeton it okay is it fair to say that
all of this stuff is garbage that all of
these journals are garbage
I think it's pretty fair to say that I
think it's pretty fair to say that at
the time of the publishing they have
seven papers accepted four of which have
been published online three more have
been accepted without having had time to
see the publication through seven papers
are still in play six were retired is
fatally flawed they had four invitations
to peer-review other papers as a result
of their own exemplary scholarship and
one paper that gained special
recognition for excellence from gender
place and culture that was the dog
humping paper just spectacular
just spectacular I love this
they said part three why did we do this
because we're racist sexist bigoted
misogynistic homophobic transphobic
trans hysterical anthropocentric
problematic privileged bullying far
right wing sis hetero straight white
males and one female who's demonstrating
her internalized misogyny and
overwhelming need for male approval we
wanted to enable bigotry preserve our
privilege and take the side of hate but
the real answer is that obviously
they're joking
the real answer is that these things are
just jar they're just chunk
post-modernism is a bag of junk it's a
bag of junk and they just proved it this
is this is so much it's basically a
stepped-up version of that story that
that was floating around for a while
from Modern Art Museum where a guy went
to a modern art museum took off his
glasses put them on the floor and then
just stood there staring at them and sin
there were a hundred people crowded
around to stare at his glasses on the
floor and did this for like five minutes
and then he reaches down picks up his
glasses wipes them off puts them on and
leaves right so that's basically that
accepts for academic studies journals I
can't believe that people are upset
about the idea of me subs
asking someone to study these topics at
college we should all be for this okay
so you know what that really should have
gone in things I like because it is the
thing that I like the most of all the
things it is so good okay but another
thing that I like so that's a
retroactive thing I like another thing
that I like
over the weekend I read a really
fantastic book it's a lot of fun to read
called Born to Run by Christopher
McDougall all about long-distance
running and the most salient part of
this book is that basically he says that
athletic sneakers are a scam that the
people who get the fewest knee and hip
injuries running are people who run
barefoot or who run with the flattest
possible shoes because when you have
really nice cushion issues it actually
teaches your body not to run properly
because you don't actually feel the
impact of each step when you're running
improperly but the book is really a it's
a page-turner it's fun to reads
basically about super endurance athletes
guys who race a hundred miles which is
you know four marathons in a row at a
time
it's pretty incredible stuff and women
and it talks about sort of the history
of man in in terms of anthropology
basically how human beings were evolved
specifically became upright walking
creature so that we could run very long
distances his theory and the theory of
some scientists is the reason we began
walking upright which has always been a
great mystery is because it allows us to
shed excess body heat and go very long
distances so you actually run down
animals so you could actually catch an
antelope but simply by running after the
antelope even though it's lower than the
antelope you can run after it
keeping it in sight until it basically
just gives out falls over and you eat it
and that that's basically why human
beings evolved the way that they did
with no hair and walking upright and
with certain muscles at the back your
neck to keep your head stable really an
interesting book Born to Run by
Christopher McDougall so that is good
stuff okay time for a couple of quick
things that I hate and then will be I
mean it's a long show but I'm sorry I
had to take time with that story was too
good okay so the things I hate list it
so Eric Holder you remember Barack
Obama's wingman remember Barack Obama's
wingman he said that he was going to
turn the AG's office into basically a
preserve of the presidency now he says
that Jeff sessions is weakening the
Attorney General position even though
Jeff Sessions is under fire even though
Jeff Sessions has done I think yeoman's
work in his job even though he has been
honest about his approach to the job
Eric Holder the most corrupt AG of my
lifetime
he says the Jeff Sessions is a real
problem I think
taking what he has taken he not only you
know weakens himself as Attorney General
it has an effect on the institution and
at some point you have to say to the
president no you've got to respond to
the president amines are extraordinary
things I've never seen a president
talked to an attorney general in the way
that this president has spoken to his
attorney general but I think you have to
respond in extraordinary ways always
thinking about how you're gonna protect
the institution yes I'm sure that that's
it I'm sure that Jeff sessions is
undermining the institution because he
hasn't quit because then I'm sure you
would love the next day gee for sure for
sure amazing stuff from Eric Holder
speaking of hypocrisy and stupidity from
the Democrats John Kerry who just will
not leave his face collapsing like a
mudslide in the Hollywood Hills growing
long or a longer each day one day his
face like an Easter Island head will
stretch all the way from the top of his
six foot floor body all the way down to
the floor where it will remain for all
eternity here is John Kerry who wants to
run for president the worst Secretary of
State in American history also a
terrible center senator and a bad human
being talking about why Ted Kennedy was
a great human being even though he left
a woman to drown in a river what about
Ted Kennedy this is it similarly people
have been critical through the years
where and he was critical of himself he
stood up and owned moments where he knew
he had stepped over the lines really so
that's the thing now Ted Kennedy owned
up he stepped up really like the guy who
put on like the fake dog collar like the
fake net collar to avoid responsibility
the guy who claimed that he had taken a
the reason that he hadn't that he'd gone
to sleep is cuz he'd taken a drug that
actually is a picker-upper go watch
Chappaquiddick if you actually think the
movie Chappaquiddick if you actually
think that what john kennedy just said
is true also Ted Kennedy the guy who was
so remorseful that he then within
basically went straight back to sexually
assaulting women along with Chris Dodd
the two of them would sandwich
waitresses at local restaurants really
this was reported by I think in New York
or 1990 1989 so yeah well done there
John Kerry just spectacular stuff all
the way through okay before I go one
mention of a company that just did me a
favor so I know many of you have been
wondering Ben what's up with that
spectacular new yarmulke on your head
now you probably didn't notice because
my yarmulke is black and I mean most
black yarmulkes look the same but if you
weren't closely watching and I know my
fans were you will notice that this
yarmulke is missing something what is it
missing it's missing bobby pins there no
bobby pins but how does it stay on your
head Ben that's the question well the
answer is that the bobby pins are
internal so for all the Orthodox Jewish
listeners that I have you know we're a
huge crowd massive growing okay for all
you folks there's something called clip
to keep us both words are with okay and
they allow you to the clips are internal
so as you can see there's no actual
bobby pin on top of your head it's it's
spectacular zoom in go go go yep got it
it's amazing okay so go check it out
clip to keep us calm so they got their
free plug good people go check them out
rail okay we will be back here at
tomorrow with all the latest insanity
because my goodness I leave for two days
and it's just madness madness we'll see
you there then I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Sonia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jesuit Vera the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright Ford publishing